en estas imágenes del ministerio de
defensa ruso se muestran camiones
militares cruzando el puente de crimea
estarían abandonando la península del
mar negro para retornar a sus bases
permanentes
pero eeuu reino unido y la otan
desconfían
hemos escuchado las señales de moscú
sobre la voluntad de continuar los
esfuerzos diplomáticos pero hasta ahora
no hemos visto ninguna desescalada sobre
el terreno por el contrario parece que
rusia continúa con la concentración
militar
militar y boudou en el otro lado también
continúa el despliegue militar así
llegaban las tropas estadounidenses a
polonia es el apoyo a sus aliados de la
otan
mientras desde el ministerio de
exteriores ruso niegan buscar la guerra
y contestan con burla o trochas de todas
esas declaraciones de stoltenberg que no
sé si es el secretario general de la
otan o un banquero no las he descifrado
y ya no nos interesan sus palabras no
son tomadas en serio en moscú es el
piloto derribado de la otan en ucrania
este miércoles se celebró el día de la
unidad nacional donde cientos de
personas salieron a exhibir la bandera y
cantar el himno en distintos puntos del
país la jornada fue declarada por el
presidente de volodymyr selenski quien
vestido de militar presenció 1º ensayos
militares y después desde mariupol
la región de dones prometió defender al
país
no tenemos miedo sea cual sea el
pronóstico no tenemos miedo de ningún
pueblo en ningún enemigo no tenemos
miedo de ninguna fecha porque nos
defenderemos mullida a pesar de las
repetidas advertencias occidentales la
temida invasión rusa todavía no se ha
producido y el presidente vladimir putin
insiste en que están comprometidos con
la diplomacia pero desde occidente
insisten en que la amenaza es real e
inminente